this has never been done before
ever
keeping a diary has fundamentally
changed my life it's the single thing
that has advanced my personal
development more than anything else that
I've done I always say there's no
personal development without
self-awareness you can read as many
books as you like but if you can't read
yourself you'll never learn a thing this
is the world's first Diary that listens
to you understands you and then provides
you with tailored support from the
world's leading experts in health
Finance work and relationships so that
you can overcome the things that are
limiting you in order to reach your
Highest Potential a limited number of
these Diaries are going to go on sale in
November and the waiting list is open
now so go to
thediary.com and add your name if you
want to come on this journey with me I
think most of us do the first date
completely wrong we set ourselves up to
fail and the reason why is because
it's so true I can't believe how true
this is
Paul Brunson the world's most
influential Matchmaker he's got a hit
show on Oprah's network you might at
first like you pay this this you may
never have heard before my expertise is
relationship science and the beauty of
science is that if you can change the
formula you change the results so if you
are someone who is in a relationship and
you're unsure how to communicate there's
certain things that you could change
tell me what those are it seems so
simple but it literally changed my
marriage so
we're terrible when it comes to making
any type of rational decision around our
love life and if you can't have
emotional intimacy you just simply can't
have a relationship you have
acquaintances you have situationships
but you don't have relationships
let's talk about sex can you be
physically attracted to somebody but
then not have sexual attraction there
are different languages sexual languages
you have to understand how your partner
the language that they speak sex in men
we need to know this 70 to 80 percent of
women need
before this episode begins I just want
to say a huge thank you to all of our
new subscribers 74 of you that watch
this channel didn't subscribe before and
we're now down to about 71 so that helps
us in a number of ways that are quite
hard to explain but simply the bigger
the channel gets the bigger the guests
get so if you haven't yet subscribed to
the Diary of a CEO if I could have any
favors from you if you've ever watched
the show and enjoyed it it's just to
please hit the Subscribe button without
further Ado I'm Stephen Butler and this
is the Diary of a CEO I hope nobody's
listening but if you are then please
keep this yourself
[Music]
okay
[Music]
give me your context what do I need to
know about you from your earliest years
from those first sort of 15 16 years of
your life that would give me the context
I need to understand the person you are
today
so I was born in Jamaica Queens you know
and I claim to fame is uh is is Curtis
Jackson 50 Cent right uh being shot nine
times in our neighborhood that's our
claim to fame but everyone's like okay I
get it that's that's where it was
um so grew up there it was a heavy
Caribbean Jamaican uh first and second
generation neighborhood but my father
was who was the first in his family to
go to college
he focused in computer science oh wow
yeah and so he you know hustled and my
mother hustled and was they we were able
to buy a home in Long Island and that
was the like you've made it you've moved
out the city and you've moved to Long
Island we were the first black family to
live in this neighborhood the first I'm
talking about a hundred homes we were
the first black family because of that
when I moved to that neighborhood I was
the underdog I was The Outsider and I
was treated as such I remember being on
the bus and just like smashed up against
the the the the glass
punched kicked you know it's one of
these where I mean for no reason like
for no reason other than the color of my
skin
um so that was that was growing up and
how has that manifested in your adult
life I'm a fighter you know I think
that's really what I you know it's
interesting I even I noticed when I walk
into a room I seek out the underdog and
I try to Champion them so if I walk into
a room I'll look for the person who's
hugging the wall the person who's in the
corner by themselves and I will
intentionally walk over to them you know
try to befriend them so this is this has
been this through line of my life is is
trying to Champion people who I feel
were the ones who were you know like me
you know smashed up against the the bus
window and you eventually went off to
University College yes what career did
you go into immediately after college
Investment Banking okay interesting
ended up hating it for the passion
explain oh my God I mean you talk about
eating you up spit you out culture you
know like here's the best here here's
how here's how I reminisce about
Investment Banking my boss at the time
was 33 years old right
uh multi-millionaire he was considered
one of the top uh so the division I was
in was uh was Banks we covered Banks so
he was one of the top investment bankers
um you know covering Banks but top
investment banker right
his wife was pregnant
at the time that we were working on a
huge deal it was the at that time it was
the largest secondary offering in the
history right of of his history but so
it's a major deal
his wife is pregnant
first child
she's starting to give birth
he decides to come into work
any sensor to the hospital
and he comes into work and I'll never
forget it he's he's walking down the the
aisle I'm like in a cubicle he's got the
office in front of me he's walking down
the aisle and people are standing up
like this
like yeah this is that's right you come
here this is the most important thing
yeah let her go off and do that right
that was the moment where I said this
place is this is like this is crazy you
know it's crazy it's ridiculous and so
that was when I started thinking okay I
need to I need to get out of here and
then you went and worked for envira no I
didn't I didn't go to Denver yet oh okay
I went off to I did what everybody does
I went to business school
and so went to business school while I
was so while I was at business school I
met enverugel didn't start working for
him but I met him so he at that time
multi-millionaire but he owned a massive
company in Turkey he was trying to
extend his business in the United States
and when I met him it was a professional
relationship and it was more so hey Paul
whenever I come to the United States I'd
love for you you to help me to schedule
meetings or help for you help me to get
booked into people because I lived in
Washington DC at the time and Capitol
Hill was there lots of senators and
Congress people and so it was easy for
me to pick up the phone work the the
network to get a meeting with it could
be Senator Hillary Clinton and so I was
helping
him at the time then I came up with a
concept to start a non-profit
organization and I needed to raise
funding or I wanted to raise funding for
it and I decided that I would ask Enver
to help me on this so that's when I
started working for envyugel how old are
you at that age I don't know that's uh
I'm 30. I'm in in the 30 Zone in your
early 30s you start your your
matchmaking company what was it about
matchmaking that
just connected with you inside and made
you because in order to to be to get
obsessed with anything to go and study
it to to then pursue it for all these
years it has to be connecting with you
because of your experiences your biases
your in a very particular way because
I'm somewhat interested in it but I
wouldn't dedicate my I wouldn't dedicate
that kind of attention to it so what was
it about you that resonated so much
about bringing people together in such a
way fair you know thinking about this
for the first time is I'm actually
connecting it to what you asked me with
regard to how I grew up right because to
me nearly every person who comes to a
Matchmaker because keep in mind
you're probably spending 10 to 20 000
you know for for matchmaking Services
you're probably allocating six to twelve
months of your life
to walk through that process it is it's
a lot right and to me ever the kernel of
every client is there there's there's a
there there's there's a feeling of
hopelessness
there's a feeling of the this is my last
shot you know there's a feeling of I am
alone you know in in this and that's
where I resonated you know I always talk
about I you know in in business you know
we talk about this fifth why right the
why that makes you cry the why that when
you're thinking about a customer
what are they thinking about at night
what's keeping them up right at night
and if you as an entrepreneur or a
business owner if you can help to solve
that problem that's keeping them up at
night the why that's making them cry
well that's that's the the secret sauce
but the key is that you have to be
passionate about that right because it's
going to take you a lot of you know
Innovations and a lot of time a lot of
energy to figure out what the formula is
but for me that that was what it was it
was there was like this level of like
I'm I'm giving up hope you know I'm just
I'm just done and also it was for a
particular Avatar which I think is also
important for a particular customer
so
you know what I've always learned in
business is that you can't serve
everyone
right so it's important to find a
particular customer specific demographic
a customer Avatar right and look for the
deepest pain Point within that
particular Avatar
now when I got into the matchmaking
space I was the first or what the
matchmaking Institute says I was the
first full-time black
Matchmaker in the United States okay
in matchmaking what a lot of people
don't like to talk about what was
happening is there was significant
segregation happening in the matchmaking
space and what was happening is that in
particular black women
were not being serviced by matchmakers
for a variety of reasons but they were
not being serviced at all
so my first customer my first avatar
were black women in particular in the we
call it the DMV DC Maryland Virginia
area and so there was a very particular
pain Point within the Avatar right and
so it was hopelessness but it wasn't
just hopelessness now that I've
described you know the Avatar right this
is someone who most likely
she's Highly Educated she's making great
money she has a child you know she is
incredible uh match for someone so so
she became my first she became my first
client and I was passionate you know why
because she was my sister-in-law she was
my auntie you know she was my cousin I
know her I live with her I've grown up
with her that was why I was so you know
so passionate about her what is What is
the relationship your parents had and
how is that influenced your work yeah
great great one they have had an
incredibly loving
relationship you know and and not just
my parents but my grandparents it's no
surprise is it because then you've had
this you know staggering long
relationship with Jill
it's funny how that you know those
generational Cycles play out over and
over again right yeah and that and
that's it that's it it's like let's
break the cycle you know we we can break
the cycle that that was that was part of
it playing out you know with my wife
Jill her parents
incredibly strong right her grandparents
on both sides
incredibly strong incredibly loving it's
an interesting question for anybody
listening to this now it's just like how
much does your relationship currently if
you're in one mirror that of your
parents and I think about you know even
the in my team here the people that have
the best relationships in my team
their parents have the best
relationships and their partner's
parents have the best relationships like
just that solid best friend type Vibes
multi-decade best friend Vibes in their
parents yes
it's interesting yeah and and so
um I agree I think if we did that we did
a you know longitudinal study around
that we would find that to be precise
but part of what I think is driving it
is I mean you could go back and look at
attachment Styles but I think largely
what's what's driving that is is seeing
what love looks like modeled before you
right and know that it's not always uh
what we consider to be lovey-dovey it
can be contentious a matter of fact
disagreements and arguments are
important
are are critical right because you need
to almost break down the relationship in
order to gain the skills to to to to to
bring it back up right and that's what
makes it stronger and so I think the
modeling is is is key it's so true so
true and I've it took me until I was 25
years to old to figure this out that
modeling point that the first model
you've been given of Love is your
parents so
you believe that to be the truth about
any person you then meet in your lives
and so you I I can remember like almost
in high definition in my mind this image
of looking over at my dad sat on the
sofa and my mom just screaming at him
and thinking
I'd [ __ ] hate to be this guy
and then I go into life and I just avoid
yes avoid every I'm obsessed about
having control yes I mean I've heard you
talk about this before yes yeah I'm
gonna say yes I mean this is that is
prototype avoidant yeah that's me
attachment style yeah right and and
what's was so interesting to me about
attachment style which by the way
um uh it's uh uh Levine Dr Levine wrote
phenomenal book called attached right on
this and I recommend for for everyone is
you know they're primarily three
categories of attachment you have secure
you have anxious and then you have
avoidant right and when you think about
this it's precisely what you just said
Stephen is that when you think of how
you first saw love and you saw it
modeled and you saw it relate to you
right was it one of which was Secure in
that you felt like you would be you know
if you were hurt you could go to a place
for safety right you would be caressed
right you'd be you'd you'd be cared for
you know that's secure but then you move
to
the avoidant right where it was you
almost having to self-soothe yourself
right which then pushes you away from
wanting to have have
anything to do with that and you become
you know what's interesting
the top and this is just me guessing
and observing
the top entrepreneurs
our avoidance
because they've had to develop the
skills to self-sustain themselves right
they've had to rely on themselves people
who are avoidant don't trust easily but
you trust yourself
right so you look at that and you say oh
my God like this came from me as a child
like it's incredible and then with the
anxious the anxious is really
interesting because the anxious was
typically a lot of parents
like my situation where your parents
worked all the time so when they were
home they would be there to give you the
love but they couldn't be home all the
time because they had to be they had to
work so then you had to substitute a
little bit so then you became anxious
about their love needy needy and this is
the person who's like texting all the
time like see I know in the past you
must have had the the girlfriend was
like Stephen Where Are You Stephen where
are you no come on
Stephen where are you where are you
where are you right all of that shows up
as adults
right uh and and also this is but but I
guess long story short is to the point
of when we've recognized that this is
why being in a relationship with someone
who is secure is so important because
you can shift your style as an adult you
can be avoidant be in a relationship
with someone who's secure and adapt to a
secure attachment
do you notice that you notice that
people who are avoidant tend to go for
people that are more secure that they go
for for the anxious
interesting right yeah yeah for needy
people yeah right because because yeah
because I mean becomes a bit of a you
know the they're chasing them and
they're they're because you know you
think about this if you're avoiding
you're pretty much self-sustained right
but if someone is anxious they're
aggressively courting you right so
they're pushing to be in your space
right so the secure unfortunately
becomes boring for so many people
safe vanilla
[Music]
it's so true I can't believe how true
this is you know but but but secure is
where it's at you know that's where it's
at you want to secure people
you want a secure in anyone else
strong secure
can help bring can help bring anyone
over too
but also you know in avoiding in anxious
can also uh you know work it's
ultimately to me it's it's about that
effort
is there such a way to so if I'm an
avoidant for example or I'm an anxious
is there work I can do myself to become
a secure without having to meet a secure
and have them bring me over yes
absolutely one of the top things someone
who is avoiding can work on
is their emotional intimacy
and that begins with simply recognizing
their emotions your emotions and
articulating them
it's it seemed it actually seems easy
but it's incredibly challenging so
uncomfortable so uncomfortable
especially for a man yes so for example
I could say Stephen how do you truly how
do you feel
right now in this moment now in this
moment very inspired and very keen to
learn okay more but very yeah okay well
I mean you did that effortlessly right
yeah but but but now the next challenge
would be okay we'll do that with your
you know with your romantic partner yeah
right and do it in spaces where you feel
vulnerable it becomes very very
challenging to say how you feel how
someone makes you feel it makes perfect
sense because there was a void in my
childhood parenting which I I've always
said has made made me an entrepreneur
but in that void as well there's a void
of like a learning affection uh so I you
know I still call my parents by their
first names I've never called the mum
and dad I we we weren't like there was
no like I love you or like hugging or
stuff stuff like that especially in my
childhood so
learning later in life to them to be
emotional and to express how I'm feeling
and to if we go friend says what's wrong
or you know how do you feel about this I
only you know I'd often just lie about
how I was feeling just for keep things
nice and calm right
um but I definitely you know it's
definitely something I've had to learn
right but I I can see
that that so I mean you're a life
learner like you're a student of life so
I can see that you have not even begun
you've you've done the work right but
for so many avoidance I'd say begun
begun okay so but for so many avoidance
that work has not yet begun and being
able to identify the emotion right and
and the feeling too because you know and
even distinguish between the emotion and
the feeling right but to be able to to
distinguish that and then to be able to
articulate that is so incredibly
important because without that you
cannot have the emotional intimacy and
if you can't have emotional intimacy you
just simply can't have a relationship
you just can't you you have
acquaintances you know you have
co-workers you know
um you have uh uh situationships you
know but you don't have relationships
that is a amazing sound bite at least
cut that into a real protect team
listening
um so there's gender differences here as
well because of of my friends both women
and men I know for a fact that my male
friends usually just push for like an
easy life yeah they just want you know
if their partner is expressing emotional
um feelings or is expressing their
emotions towards them
most of my male friends will see that as
an attack
you know
and like they they just don't want to go
there it's it's this energy that men
just don't like so I was watching this
funny Twitter video before I came down
here and it's this woman she's cooked
dinner for her husband and she's proving
that men just won't tell you the truth
she puts loads of salt in it to make it
taste awful and she walks into the front
room while he's watching the game and
she goes try this hun tell me what you
think and you see his face just works
and it's [ __ ] disgusting and he goes
yeah
and for me it's summed up man it's like
we just want to avoid the heat like we
literally literally you're not so I have
a theory on this right so I'm I'm
testing this one out right but but I
call it the feedback loop Theory so my
wife was in HR yeah before she joined me
in the matchmaking space and one of the
things that they would do uh in their
company she worked in this Law Firm is
that they would uh you know extensive
feedback during the review period
extensive feedback so
you know how was your year how did you
perform all of these these kpis right
and that feedback would translate into
higher performance I mean just
bottom line and what I've noticed with
women
typically typically with women is that
whenever there's a romantic experience
that romantic experience is then shared
with like 10 of their friends you know
it's like go out on a date
the WhatsApp group knows everything
that's happening in on on the date and
then there's a debrief of the date
there's an analysis of the date here's
what he did here's what I wore blah blah
blah blah this happens for three days
constant feedback and that feedback ends
up making women I think on average
better daters right better equipped to
deal and manage in relationships now
Stephen when you were single tell me
this if you were going on a date right
who do you talk to about the date
nobody
yeah it's so it's all it's all in your
head it's like okay I might tell one of
my friends I might say oh I saw this
person the other night you know when I
was single I would have gone you know I
saw Ruby like three days ago and she was
that was it was fun yeah yeah he was
like all right cool yeah yeah and that's
it there's no feedback and think about
this think about not that just happening
on one date but that happening month
after month year after year 10 15 years
of no feedback we're all in our head we
have no idea like how to perform how to
up our performance and that impacts
what happens when we eventually get into
the relationship so I think the feedback
loop there's really something to it and
I've noticed it's primarily a gender
difference so are you saying also that
because women are have a community where
they're discussing stuff they're
discussing feelings and what happened
they try and bring that same energy to a
man who's just not used to it and he
goes [ __ ] how like I I don't know
like I you know what I mean and he's
just like trying to avoid going there
because he's never really had to go
there before never had to never had to
when you dig into the data and this is
what I love about
love like in particular I always say
that my expertise is relationship
science right I like to look at the
science of love
and look at how that impacts how we show
up and why we show up and the beauty of
science is that if you can change the
the formula not necessarily a formula if
you change the equation right you change
the result and that's the beautiful
thing so if you are someone who is in a
relationship and you're unsure how to
communicate there's certain things that
you could change to make the
communication stronger make the
relationship better tell me what those
are oh my God there's so many what are
the like foundational things that have
worked for you and your clients in terms
of like communication conflict
resolution okay great great question uh
okay so a couple things and even with uh
not only with my clients but but with my
wife you know so this this seems so
basic I think it's talked about but not
even talked about enough is Gary
Chapman's five love languages it seems
so simple but it literally changed my
marriage so by you know there's
something called the the the The
Five-Year itch and The Seven Year Itch
typically in marriages not committed
relationships but marriages where you
literally see separation rates and
divorce rates increase at that five and
seven year mark right you also see it
happen when uh they become when
marriages become you become empty
nesters your you know kids go off to
school
but right around that five and seven
year mark
I was sleeping on the couch at my house
like it was not good you know in our
household and this was so small but so
significant is I bought Dr Gary
Chapman's five love languages right
which outlines right five ways that we
recognize and see love but here was the
power of it the power of it was that my
wife I thought she was spoiled
because all she wanted was gifts like
she was like buy me this buy me that's
my birthday buy me this it's Christmas
buy me this it's Monday buy me this
right it was by me right and I thought
to myself Jesus she's spoiled like this
is crazy so what do I do Stephen I bet
you would do the same thing
you know what I did well I said I'm not
gonna buy you anything
you know because you're spoiled I'm
gonna change this Behavior you know I'm
not gonna buy you a thing so what
happens when it's her birthday it's
Christmas it's the anniversary it's
Monday and I'm not buying her anything
oh man like hell it becomes hell
but it was Dr Gary Chapman's book that
helped me understand that the way that
my wife grew up
the way that she saw love through her
parents were through gifts
father spoiled her to death right and
her father loved her and showed his love
showered his love through gift through
gift giving so she as a little girl is
growing up thinking okay you know I get
the doll I get this I get this right
this is love this is love this is love
her love language is legitimately gifts
I had to understand that fundamentally
to understand that this is how she will
see that I love her it's not just simply
through maybe what's you know uh you
know acts of service which is which is
my love language right do something on
my behalf yeah right so I would do
something on her behalf right but no it
was it's
gifts and then for her to know okay for
me it's acts of service so if she you
know she was big on gifts giving me
gifts and I was like I don't I don't I
don't resonate with this you know I
don't get this and so
fought the understanding truly
understanding
your partner's love language
and then giving them love in that
language is a game changer and a quick
way to determine someone's love language
is just observe how they show love
to the people they love right what do
they do right that's that's a quick way
so so so love languages game changer
Game Changer right so so that's one
um secondly is to I think to understand
that you you need to argue right but
great relationships are bids you're
putting in bids it's a constant tennis
match
that's a great relationship constant
tennis match so what that means is that
you are showing through your action
through your love language through your
words Etc but you're showing that you
love your partner and you're doing that
consistently over and over and over and
over and over again and what your
partner is going to be doing is they're
going to hit that ball back to you and
you're going to hit that ball back to
them but you have to remember this one
thing sometimes you have to hit the ball
five times over
right the net before they return the
ball to you and ultimately what that
means is that you have to consistently
remind your partner so you could be I'm
21 years into my marriage people think
all right you're 21 you're good you
don't have to do anything now right it's
smooth sailing no when I get home today
I am still showing up recognizing that I
have to continually put those bids in
you know I always say it's like Janet
Jackson what have you done for me lately
that's truly what a relationship is is
that it's constantly it's this constant
constant right and then part of that
that constant too maybe this is just a
third concept
super simple but
intentional time
intentional time so so what what I find
really interesting is you look at
how much time we spend with our our
partners or our spouse it's one to two
hours a day on our on average the
average married couple spends one to two
hours per day
so you think about that you're probably
spending more time with the bus driver
than you are with with your spouse and
then in the one to two hours what are
you actually doing
it's like ships passing in the night you
know no real conversation one's watching
TV in this side one's on the computer
over here no real communication and what
ends up happening is you're not able to
exchange ideas you're not able to talk
about you know dreams you're not able to
talk about hopes you're not able to talk
about your feelings you know you're not
able to connect
intentional time spent I always say that
you know effort always equals interest
but whatever is important to you in life
you have to be intentional about
spending time on it you know and that
includes the relationship that includes
it and so intentional time so that may
mean okay every Friday we're having
dinner together where every night we're
having to in my household it's every
night we have dinner together as a
family I help I try to rearrange my
schedule so that I'm at home with my
family having dinner and if I get home
too late to have dinner with my boys my
wife and I are having dinner at 11 PM 12
midnight but we are communing together
right this is very important
uh you know we talk about you know
weekly dates
but the whole bottom line is spending
time this Saturday my wife and I we have
a date right yeah 21 years into our
marriage still planning dates still
excited about the dates it's intentional
time spent intentional time spent so I
mean there's there's so many Concepts
but
I would say that if you just do those if
you just think about that those basics
love language right understanding that
relationships are always a bid it's
always a bid back and forth always and
sometimes you have to bid five six times
before you get the ball back right but
it's always bid and then it's
intentional time spent you you know you
you typically you typically you
typically grow together opposed to
growing apart
you're on the couch
five years in right yes the the only way
off that couch with all of those things
said is like communication you have to
at some point you're gonna have to have
a tough conversation about something yes
um in business in life and in everything
and what I've noticed is most of the
issues I have in my life uh have become
big issues because I didn't have an
honest conversation about something
sooner when I knew it was a problem so I
deferred I knocked it back whatever
um the art of having
a good healthy conversation with someone
with a partner with someone you love
when there's a lot of emotion and
tension is something that I don't think
we've talked about enough in in society
specifically men really struggle I think
with that how does how does one have a a
good conflict resolution orientated
conversation without you know [ __ ]
screaming or walk running out or
whatever or blame you know yeah yeah no
I hear you and and I agree and I I hear
This this term uh passed around a lot
and I agree with it is is that the more
challenging conversations you have in
life the higher quality your life is
because most of us try to run away as
you're saying right so I think there are
a couple things that we could do one is
sometimes
you won't be equipped to have that
conversation or your partner won't be
equipped to have that conversation
that's the importance of having a third
party right this is the reason why you
know therapy is so incredibly important
and I and I really try to preach this
because I feel like the UK is a little
bit behind the U.S you know when it
comes to that is therapy is sexy you
know having a counselor is sexy you know
what I mean so having a third party a
professional one that's very important
secondly is is uh is is context picking
the right moments to have these
challenging conversations picking the
right environments to have these
conversations are incredibly important
right you could you could we could
decide that we can have this argument in
the kitchen when we know that the boys
have to be in bed in five minutes and I
know it's been a long day for you and I
haven't slept last night we could have
this conversation right now if you want
to it's probably not going to go in the
direction we wanted to or we could wait
and hold on until Saturday when we're
both taking that walk back from dropping
the boys off at their at their at their
class and we have 10 minutes to sit in
the park and talk about this so to have
the right context is incredibly
incredibly important
third
I think if I'm giving top three is to
actually set rules and boundaries
and this does not happen enough in
relationships and I always say that if
you don't set boundaries you will take
even well-intentioned partners and turn
them into bullies
you don't set your boundaries so you
have to set your boundaries from the
beginning of the relationship but in
particular when you're having these
tough conversations and boundaries could
be as simple as we're going to focus on
one topic when you're having an uh a
discussion the discussion should be
about the topic at hand right but
setting what those boundaries are ahead
of time because typically what ends up
happening is fights become unfair right
it's healthy to fight but it's unhealthy
to fight in an unfair manner so I think
those are those are three three
techniques that I know that you know
Jill and myself that we use when we are
having our discussions
quick one from our longest standing
sponsor hero
I I can't tell you over the last I'd say
over the last really it's been about two
and a half years it was really um post
pandemic how much my health has become
such a huge priority in my life huel has
been probably the most important partner
in my health Journey because
I've been in the boardrooms I've been to
their offices
tens and tens and tens and tens of times
I've seen how they make their decisions
on nutrition and I trust it I trust the
brand to keep me nutritionally complete
and that is something that I fight for
every single day and the chaos and the
busyness of my life and that's why it's
such a wonderful thing to be able to
talk to this audience about a brand and
a product that is so unbelievably linked
to my values and the the place I am in
my life of valuing the gym exercise
movement my mind my breathing and all of
those things and most importantly my
nutrition that is the role fuel plays
and so if you haven't already tried Hill
and you've been resistant to my my
pestering then give it a go and let me
know how you get on
quick word from one of my sponsors
um super excited to announce that our
new sponsor for the podcast is Intel a
brand that pretty much every single
person listening to this is a user of
but in some cases you might not even
know for those that don't know Intel is
a technological Powerhouse who have been
driving Technology Innovation and
transformation for more than 50 years we
all know that technology has never been
more important than it is today and
Intel is truly shaping the future of our
industry from keeping us connected
through 5G which we use in all of our
lives every single day to modernizing
computers to transforming businesses
through data and analytics the list goes
on and on and on I've been particularly
excited to announce the sponsorship
because we've been using Intel's
technology throughout this building and
on this podcast for some time now and it
makes our lives so much easier in so
many ways especially as it relates to
producing this show for you so head over
to intel.co.uk and you can find out why
they've become an essential piece of
technology in my day-to-day routine let
me know what you think at some point
um you started a YouTube channel and
Oprah got in touch yes that's crazy it's
crazy it's it's uh it's crazy but it is
uh
you know so
when I decided to launch my matchmaking
business after I'd spent a year prepping
I didn't know how to launch it and it
was my wife and my best friend at the
time who said you know you should focus
on the marketing aspect of this you
should start a YouTube channel now this
is
2009
[Music]
so like early early were you born in
2000 not just about
so you know so 2009 so YouTube isn't a
big it's a thing it's not as big a thing
as it is right now it's not known as the
go-to place to Market your new company
um but I decided to create a YouTube
series called the modern day Matchmaker
and what I decided is I would pump all
of my money into this thing and I I mean
when I look around the studio this is an
impressive studio
um I had like one out of ten of these
cameras I had like one camera you know
but it was me spending a thousand to
four thousand dollars per production
minute right so we had a team yeah I
know it's crazy it's ridiculous
but the reason why is because I thought
I had a unique point of view and if I
can just push that out into the
marketplace I could distinguish myself
from the competitors
and I would put out this video every
week man and nobody would watch it
nobody and and I say this and this is
not even a joke is every week it would
get like 11 or 12 views this video and
my mother was watching nine of those you
know and so it was no one was watching
this thing but I thought this was a way
for me to
you know from for me to at least create
my brand within the space
now it turns out that one of those 11
views was Oprah
people say like okay how did Oprah find
you you know
the reason why Oprah was able to find me
is because a year prior
I was doing pro bono matchmaking
services
free work free work
one of my clients and I had no idea but
one of my clients was a writer
for O magazine
a year later she's on Oprah's jet
Oprah
says I have a concept for a new TV show
I'm looking for a fresh voice
my client in the jet says have you heard
of Paul Brunson Oprah says no but let me
see
YouTube search Paul Brunson
save let me start watching so Oprah was
watching this YouTube series and and you
know when I always look at it I say gosh
to me it is a powerful story because she
ends up offering me a job to co-host a
television show with her on her brand
new network
off of this YouTube series that no one
was watching but Oprah my mother and
like two other people
and I say it's a powerful story about
quality over quantity you know I think
we live in a day and age where you know
vanity metrics in particular are are
everything you know it's like I need to
have this number of followers this
number of views and I get it to a
certain extent it is important when
you're monetizing But ultimately The Who
that's watching is more important and it
was it was through that that you know
that that YouTube series that I I got
the job and it and working with Oprah
changed my life there's this thing
called like lagging metrics
um in kpis and business and analytics
where the the metrics that show up later
once you've done the input once you've
done the work and I was thinking about
that as you're speaking because you were
doing you were doing focusing on quality
now the lagging metric was that you were
going to become an Oprah Winfrey Show
and she was gonna watch
but you were just planting the seeds of
quality and and like I'm sure that if
you carried on doing that channel for 15
years it would have probably had 15
million subscribers but but in fact I
always think about it like seeds even
with even with what we've done here if I
showed you the graph of the growth of
the diver Co it's literally this is no
exaggeration I posted on my Twitter the
day it's two years
flat right
now what happens next is it goes like a
like a vertical lineup well well and you
never know
when or how or whatever but those first
two years when it was flat was when all
of those seeds were being planted and
really where you're you're learning your
craft
and I think so many people
um it's important for so many people
because the big metrics always lag
behind and things go fast then things go
slow then fast yes and uh we sometimes
can get super impatient about where why
isn't Oprah called me yet why don't I
have a big podcast for 10 15 million
download why don't I have that yet
but you're doing the work now to have
that in that quiet period And I loved
what you said there about like the
quality like if you just focus on
quality which is something you know you
can control just making whatever you're
doing now like the best yes you have
nothing to worry about you don't need to
worry you just need patience yes yes and
and I love that when I hear that that
story because 11 views one of them
[ __ ] Oprah is just yeah it's it's a
mind blow it's a it's a mind blow and
and I think to to even add to what
you're saying is I think that that's the
key of having the passion because that's
I mean that's the reason why like yeah
you keep on keeping on you keep on
keeping on because because otherwise the
first hurdle you hit you give up right
and you should because you're [ __ ]
stupid go get a job
can you imagine he was like what are you
doing you just came from Investment
Banking like I mean honestly Steven the
amount of people who thought I was
crazy like commit this guy he left
Investment Banking and he's doing
YouTube videos out of his bedroom and
he's not paying for his mortgage right
his wife my wife liquidated her
retirement fund so so we had burned
through our money
she liquidates her retirement fund
and we start using that as capital for
the business and the capital is being
used for a YouTube series that 11 people
are watching like people thought I was
nuts
that's it I think Steve Jobs said it he
said you know there's going to become a
day when you're doing what you're doing
where any sane person would give up and
they should give up but faced with the
facts and numbers that you'll see before
you but those that keep going are those
that are doing it for that really deep
internal reason and like one of the
things I know for sure is that no matter
what business you start unless you're
very very lucky exceptionally lucky
you're gonna have those days and there's
not gonna be one of them it's going to
be for most people week months sometimes
multiple years where everything is
saying you're an idiot you should stop
right and the only way you Grace those
hurdles is because
sometimes because you don't have a plan
B that's a very good way to just keep on
keeping on but because it's a challenge
that you must pursue right regardless of
remuneration or outcome it's for you and
so when I bet on entrepreneurs
especially when I'm investing in them
I'm looking for that I'm like I because
I don't I don't know always a ton about
the industries but what I do know is a
ton about the nature of business and I
know your hard days are coming how will
you respond for that three years where
everything is bad right resilience you
know purpose all of those sort of key
indicators so Oprah you end up working
with Oprah on her show
I guess I got two questions first one is
what did you learn from Oprah working so
closely with her well the first thing I
learned was not to color Oprah
no no no no no no no no you could call
if you were working
for her
she's Miss Winfrey
that was the first thing I learned
someone corrected me very quickly I was
like oh no they said no this went free
you know uh so that that was the first
thing but she is
everything you can imagine that she is
times a hundred
but also too was interesting to me about
about Miss Winfrey about Oprah is that
when she would speak
you never knew if she was talking about
the event in the immediate or she's
giving you some you know life advice
like I remember the the very first scene
I shot with her was we were in Georgia
so we shot a show called love Town USA I
actually did two shows with Oprah but
the first one was love Town USA and
there's 10 000 people in this audience
they're all there to see Oprah there's
this massive light kit on stage it's big
it's my first big event ever I've never
spoken in front of 10 like I've never
spoken in front of 10 people you know 10
000 people
and the director comes over and he was
like all right Paul get up on stage hit
your mark and introduce Oprah
he's thinking hit my mark what is a mark
like what does that mean and I'm
freaking out I'm sweating
and Oprah comes over to me real calm
cool puts her hand on my on my shoulder
she's like all right baby look this is
it's real simple you just walk on that
stage keep walking until you feel the
light hit you the brightest
that's where you stay right and I was
thinking to myself is she talking about
the stage is she talking about life like
because that's deep you know but that's
how she would speak
um and she was uh she just Just Amazing
Just just amazing amazing amazing person
why is she successful in your assessment
why is she Oprah Oprah what is it about
her yeah so I I studied her
you know I'm a people Watcher you know
uh and I worked for so I worked for
Oprah after I worked for Enver
and the similarity to me is that when I
started working for Enver he went from
multi-millionaire to billionaire and
that to me was was really interesting
because of how few billionaires you know
there are in in the world so I started
to journal what I learned from Enver
then I start working for Oprah and I
noticed similarities
and what was wild to me is here are two
people who are completely different you
know one woman one man went from the U.S
one turkey when married one not one
Christian one Muslim it's like
completely different but yet they had
these same characteristics and for Oprah
in particular
you know I noticed we used to go on
these Road shows for the show to sell
the show to to advertisers and before
the road show she would also she would
always host a dinner
and these dinners there would be you
know 20 30 people at the dinner you'd
have all types of athletes and
politicians and uh you know she would
have her she would bring her some of her
girls from her school in South Africa
would also be at the table it would be
this potpourri this eclectic Buffet of
various people and she would sit and she
would conduct these these amazing
dinners and I realized that at these
dinners that was her education
but it was the dinner like she was being
educated on what was happening in the
world what's going to happen tomorrow
right because she had a lot of The
Playmakers at the table she was learning
about different perspectives she was
teasing out her own ideas and debating
them before she would take them on
screen she would do this in these
intimate dinner settings I noticed Enver
would do the same thing massive dinners
20 30 people every night he would have
these massive dinners and he would do
the same thing they they would they
would you know they the concept is Never
Eat Alone you know Keith farazi has a
book called Never Eat Alone which I
think is a phenomenal book but it's
about the power of
socializing and the power that you get
from
from essentially strengthening your the
weak ties in your network
interesting I think I'm quite bad at
socializing
you you know so I was gonna say I'm
wondering if there's like a digital
equivalent or if like I'm doing it right
now yes see I think this this is your
extension but so okay so let's let's
even tease this out a little bit so Mark
granoveter who was a Stanford Professor
came up with this theory of of weak ties
right so if you take robin Dunbar right
who has the Dunbar rule we have roughly
150 friends essentially right you could
debate it out but on average right
um
if you think about your 150th friend the
weakest
friends right the 140th friend right
acquaintance acquaintance right those
are where our biggest opportunities in
life come
that's where deals come for our business
that's where we get introduced to
spouses right that's where
you know tickets to the football game
come it comes from the weakest ties
opposed to our nearest and dearest which
you think about you think God is that
even logical but it is our weakest ties
Drive the most opportunity in our life
but what do we do most of us we spend
all of our time where
with the people closest to us
but what Oprah and Enver do and what
Mark granoveter talks about with this
theory is that the key is to constantly
be strengthening our weak ties investing
in those weak ties adding new people in
to our weak ties kicking other other
people out and that's what they're doing
those people at that table those were
not her Besties
those were not her top five right those
were her 120th 130th and that's where
the enormous opportunity comes in
testing so your matchmaking business
becomes from what I read one of the
largest matchmaking companies in the
United States yes how long did that take
the Paul C Brunson agency oh my God that
was two thousand so I was 2008 to 2016.
so eight years
two of all the avatars
of the sort of personas
do you find struggles with being alone
the most oh my you know it
men really yeah and I would even say uh
you know I mean you know there's a whole
in-cell movement yeah right uh but but
and you know there's lots of Articles
now about the the rise of of the lonely
man you know uh but quite honestly
or at least from experience remember
this is 2016. slightly you know slightly
different time but
successful
men and I when I say financially
successful so those who were the
investment bankers
who
45 years old retired from Investment
Banking thinking about their next career
divorced twice
sitting at home alone
right
that's where the struggle that's where
it hits you you know when you realize oh
my God I'm 45. I'm I've only lived half
my life you know and here I am alone and
I'm a dick
on top of it right so that's
that was that was the demo that was
there was a struggle
I gotta be honest when I asked you that
question about which group of people
would struggle the most with
loneliness my head bounced around I
thought I think he's gonna say
potentially
um younger men because of this whole
in-cell thing where you know I don't
want to get into the mass shootings and
stuff but kid you know young men who
have I had a guest on this podcast Scott
Galloway who talked about how
like
90 of the female attention even when you
think about things like Bumble goes to
like the top five ten percent of men yes
and then you've got this kind of the
other 40 do okay then you've got the
bottom 50 of men that are totally just
not getting that haven't been laid from
for more than a year I think that's what
he said
um so I thought maybe you'd go for them
then I thought he's gonna say
30 plus women
because of things like biological clocks
and stuff like that right
um and this sort of social pressure
which I I I've heard from guests here
that some women can feel because of
society's expectations and timelines to
like to hurry up and be married so I
thought you would say one of those two
groups so to hear you say a completely
different group yeah was quite
surprising yeah no I hear you and and
what you said that's a logical it's a
logical breakout but for me and this is
my experience is dealing with those who
are seeking matchmaking you know
is that the thought is
time is over
you know my my the Heyday is gone you
know it's kind of like the the athlete
that
is now retired
but one but still desires to play but
realizes that they don't have you know
they don't have it anymore but a rich 44
year old man yes has got options has you
know what a Rich Ford yeah has options
but but we're talking about loneliness
though okay right and there's an
emptiness that does come over you when
you realize you know so a large part of
loneliness unfortunately is through
comparison because you know this whole
idea when we compare we despair we
despair upon ourselves so a large part
of that is is that you look across your
peers and you say look at this now
Stephen's married you know he's two
children you know and I'm yeah I'm out
here I have my Ferrari you know but I
come home to myself in my big house in
my big in my massive house and there's
there's and there's no one here with me
and you're astute enough to know that
all of those people who you thought were
loyal to you were actually not loyal to
you but they were just loyal to their
circumstances with you and the job and
stuff yeah the job right exactly so so
you begin to understand oh my God
they're not my friends I I have I I have
no one and so
when you have someone to go to a
Matchmaker typically they have
reached the end of their line when it
comes to their hope
you know and I think that
from my peers
who are of that age or I'll say of that
vintage right that
it is uh you know it's it's it's
incredibly sad
it's just it's just incredibly sad now I
think what women do tremendously well or
should I say better than men of that age
is they understand how to build
community
and that's something that
goes back to what we were talking about
before we talked about you know the
feedback loop
we talked about uh you know challenges
around being emotionally available
especially at an early age understanding
how to build emotional intimacy the
these
these things all play themselves out not
only in our romantic relationships but
in our platonic relationships and what
we have to understand is that these the
stronger platonic relationships we have
the more
Health we have
the longer we live the more money you
know you know we we make you know I have
a so I have a it's my wife's uh aunt she
is 111 years old
so she's one of the oldest
human beings right now on the planet
she's a hundred and eleven incredibly
astute and when I sit down I just sit
down and I'm just I absorb everything
that she says and what I realize is she
still has friends
like at 111
she's friends that she talks to every
day you know that's how you stay alive
you know we we focus and I get it you
know gut health is so important and low
cholesterol is so important yeah I I get
it right exercise is so important right
I get all those things are so important
but I would argue that our social
connections
are even more important and we have to
understand how to build
the skills
and you do that before like I always say
the best time to work on your marriage
is before you get married you know the
best time to work on your friendships
before you have your friend right we
need to develop these skills early on
someone said to me in fact yesterday so
ring surgery is what you're saying that
um we were talking about resilience
and they said we used to think of
resilience as like being tough yourself
but when we look at different people the
resilience comes from being surrounded
by Community a supportive community and
that in fact makes a person an
individual resilient psychologically
resilient so when I think about that
investment banker that's 45 years old
and alone he doesn't have a community to
help keep his psychological resilience
in place and there's this thing there's
this really interesting study that I
that I read about
um and this goes back to our sort of
ancestral backgrounds where we lived
together in these tight-knit communities
where if someone the reason why when
people are lonely they they live less
long and they're more susceptible to
illness disease and all of these other
things is because scientists have seen
that the brain literally goes into a
state called self-preservation where
your sleep so think about it if you left
your tribe and you're out on the I don't
know the Serengeti when we were I don't
know tens of thousands of years ago
whatever
everything's check everything changes in
terms of your your keeping yourself
Alive You Can't Sleep the same so they
observe the brain of someone who's
lonely and they struggle with sleep
because we've been programmed to [ __ ]
stay up because the lion might be coming
right and this is really interesting
there's all these dots are connecting in
my brain now because I started learning
about this thing called chronotypes
where
all of us and a group of 20 30 people
what you'll find is they all have
completely different sleeping rhythms
when they get hungry when they're most
creative when they have the most power
so I'm an owl my my partner was was the
opposite yes and the reason why we have
these different chronotypes again it
goes back to the tribal days where like
we didn't all want to sleep at the same
time right or be alert at the same time
so we create a community where we're
basically one Shield of the tribe to
survive and thinking about that guy
who's 45 years old he's got the bag but
he's lonely as [ __ ] he's in
self-preservation yeah that's a great
point you know that's that's
physiologically your brain is completely
different
uh when you fall into a state of
loneliness and because your body's
trying to help you survive in this
dangerous potentially dangerous World
from the Lions out there yeah the other
thing they noticed was when someone was
lonely is their levels of resentment
like the snappiness the like anger the
all of that went up as well and that
links to what you said about they don't
learn the skills to form connections
because they've got so used to
self-defense like psychological
self-defense yeah yeah and I can see
that if you're in that state then you
just delve deeper into that as each year
ago like you become a curmudgeon like
you become Russia yeah yeah recluse from
it's just it's that that to me is sad
because you have someone who you pers
you perceive them to have it all yeah
but they really have nothing
and it makes sense because if I was if I
got used to being alone say I was on the
in the I don't know I don't even know
where prehistoric humans used to live
just in the savannah of Africa because
we're all from Africa right and I've got
so used to living alone when I see
someone else or a tribe I'm not gonna be
like hey I'm gonna think these [ __ ]
are gonna kill me I'm going to hide yeah
yeah trust goes down you're
apprehensive yes you know all of those
things that you actually described early
on that happens and that makes perfect
sense yeah yeah what do you do though so
in that case of that investment banker
what is step one to get them from that
point when they're on the couch they've
got all that money in that Mansion
they're alone how to get them out there
and find someone to love them yeah I
mean therapy you know with so with
matchmaking one of the things that we
introduced we we were Pioneers in many
ways one way is that
you would come to us and we wouldn't
just simply find dates for you we you
would come to us and then we would
assign you to a therapist that you'd
work with for three to six months before
you went on your date right so there's
this Rehabilitation you know that takes
place and and what I always say about
therapy too is it's not you go to a
therapist and you're fixed you know it's
you begin to build the muscle and you
continue that right so that would be a
place to begin secondly is to begin
friendships is where I would go so it's
not like okay how can I place you in a
community of 10 people but how can I
find one person that you could begin to
build a relationship with and start with
building Rapport you know very basic
very you know very very basic very slow
but that's how I would begin you know
also talking about that particular
client because you know it's been some
while since I've been matchmaking but
now he's coming back to me
um
very you know what I found with men of
that particular vintage right and the
dating scene is is that the a lot of the
the body movements were I would call odd
right the there was a social ineptness
you know
um that needed to be worked out you know
Bodyline we say more with our body than
than we do with our words and
there was a uncomfortableness you know
that took months to to tease out and
this is especially if you are coming
from a career where you are the
Authority you were the boss you're
you're the top dog so you don't have a
level of
no one is critiquing
your body language right but now you
move to a social situation where your
entire interaction is largely based on
your body language it's it's a different
situation so
it takes it takes months right or it
could take years but it takes a while of
work before you know before we we begin
the matchmaking
I'm like slowly developing a theory on
Awkward Huggers do you know what I mean
those people that are like okay
they kind of give you a tap on the back
oh my gosh yeah can I okay can we talk
about hugging for a second 100 I noticed
that men do this so so I have a buddy
named Tom Reed Wilson who's on one of
the shows with me and he taught me
something that I now pay close attention
to so most men I notice hug and tap the
back get the [ __ ] off
right but what Tom taught me is the hold
and embrace and hold and embrace for 30
seconds which is a long freaking time to
embrace someone wow and what he taught
me was that in that Embrace to notice
how uncomfortable the person is with you
there's a okay you're gonna let me go is
this is odd now this is not to a
stranger but this is this is someone who
you would hug opposed to the Pat is is
is the hug that to me is wild but here's
a here's another wild one that men do
this I learned this from Robin Dunbar
also in his book friendship
is and and if you see two men talking to
each other at a party out on the street
they normally stand at at like a 120
degree angle rarely do they stand like
this never would they stare like this
because going back to us on the
Serengeti right this is very
confrontational right this means we're
about to kill each other you know but
like this we're safe you know if we
cheat our bodies like this the 100 Twin
Creek and and if you notice that men do
that all the time now ladies walk right
up
how you doing girl you know but men it's
like okay yeah yeah yeah don't hug me
yeah yeah yeah so but but the these see
these are all things that we we laugh
when we joke about
but
it suggests why we could have challenges
in our intimate relationships
one of the things I've been curious
about that I have a lot of question
marks around is this idea of
compatibility and who who we're
compatible with are we just you know
because when we think about dating we
often think about it like we're trying
to find this perfect individual that we
could kind of draw on a piece of paper
that has all of these particular
qualities we think we know who we're
looking for
um is that true what what do I need to
know about like what truly makes someone
compatible because I think once upon a
time for sure for sure I would have said
I want my partner to be probably like me
right I would have said earlier if I can
run a huge business so we can talk about
it in bedtime and right
I didn't think that's the case anymore
yeah yeah I mean my my joke is that most
men who came to us right they want
themselves with a vagina
pretty much that's pretty much what
they're looking for right
um so
uh this is a topic that's you know I've
been studying forever and there's a lot
of different thoughts around it like if
you just think about dating apps
they spent an enormous amount of money
trying to perfect the algorithm to you
know the matching algorithm it's all
about that and if you look at the
success rate so the percentage of people
who are using dating apps and then end
up in a committed or committed
relationship or marriage and then stay
in that for a fixed amount of time like
10 years it's like less than two percent
so you think okay so they haven't gotten
it right there's certain matchmakers
that profess to have
almost near 100 success rates you say
what do they do you know I have some
friends who just say I can just look at
you and tell and you're like whatever
like you know
but over time there are certain areas
that I firmly believe firmly believe
determine whether or not you have strong
compatibility right so one we've already
talked about attachment style yeah I
think attachment style incredibly
important we've talked about values
values incredibly important that's the
rule book to life right another part of
it is your ability to communicate so
there's this Theory called decide versus
slide right it's a theory that a lot of
uh you know you have you have people
like John cottman's behind this would be
you've people in the states who
have looked at when you're with your
partner
can you make a decision together on
anything let's say you're with your
partner and you decide okay we're going
on vacation can you actually make
decisions on where you're going without
killing each other like can you decide
what you're going to eat without killing
each other like can you actually make
collaborative decisions that is deciding
versus sliding what a lot of
relationships a lot of couples do is
they say okay no you decide that
you'd pick where we're going to go I'll
decide where we're going to do right
it's a slide it's not a collaborative so
when you were uh dating when you're
engaged it's very important to begin to
look at are you making decisions
together do you have the ability to make
decisions together right deciding versus
sliding very important another one
that's touchy for a lot of people but it
is what it is is you know
do you have physical attraction there's
a massive debate I don't understand why
there's still a debate over this is that
every bit of science suggests to us that
if you have zero I'm talking about zero
physical attraction it's going nowhere
like it's going nowhere but if you have
minimal physical attraction it doesn't
mean rip the clothes off energy but if
you have minimal physical attraction
then that could build because you could
be you know you could be sapiosexual
where it's the intellect that drives you
but you still have to have a minimal
level of physical attraction and then
what we see is that over time attraction
can definitely grow but it needs to
start somewhere so you think about
physical attraction you think about the
ability to make decisions compatibility
in values also attachment style these
become I think the foundational pieces
to having
a a compatible relationship but then
there's this small little piece that I
want to throw out and this is some
studies that have been done in the U.S
that I find to be fascinating is
the marriage rate
you know in the UK as well it it hovers
you know between let's say 35 and 50
depending on who who you're talking to
or should I say the divorce rate does 35
to 50 so the idea is there that almost
half of people who get together end up
getting a divorce on average
now if you were to just take out
couples who have been engaged for two
years
what do you think that does to the
divorce rate so they've been engaged for
two years and then they get married
uh I think the divorce rate goes down
exactly it goes down dramatically some
people say it goes down to 20 20 22
right chance of getting divorced if
you've been if you had a long engagement
yes
now why would that be
the reason why is because you're able to
test out all of these theories you're
able to see your partner in the most
adverse circumstance and see do they
still show up as as yeah can they still
make a decision with me you know or do
they emotionally shut down and and they
go away
so then when you look at
why or the couples where you see divorce
being prevalent it's in couples in one
of two categories one they've known each
other for a year or less right it's
quick or when I say no each other
they've been a committed relationship
for a year less or they've been in
committed relationship for like 10 years
and it's like basically you know it was
an ultimatum and that's the reason why
why they were married so the two years
of Engagement I think is incredibly
important because it allows you to test
out these compatibility metrics
two things there so the first one I
wanted to just jump back to because I
found it really interesting and it's
something I've thought about
a lot because of some of my friends and
my circle is
can you be because you talked about
physical attraction can you be
physically attracted to somebody
but then not have sexual attraction uh
okay I say this because I remember in a
past relationship I was physically
attracted to her
but sexually I just it just didn't work
and that's why that relationship ended
she was this beautiful
girl her her breath like her mind her
intellect she was super smart she was
super funny she was just everything I
think there's a point before we went to
have sex that I thought this is it this
is the one we then went to have sex
and I I've never said this before I
remember getting up and going over to my
phone and like afterwards like and
saying to one of my best mates I just
get I don't think I can ever see her
again see I wonder how much of this
though plays into to to to foreplay
really because have you heard have you
heard about uh erotic blueprint
I've heard about it I've heard it on
that goop show okay yeah yeah it was it
was on group two really yeah I watched
that yeah so you know so and and I I buy
into that theory which you know the
overall premise is is that you know we
all
um we we all become sexually stimulated
in different ways yeah right and the the
thought is that men are just ready all
the time like you know yeah it's like
we're right like we're just ready you
know come on in the room like we're just
ready but that's not the case you know
some of us it's about you know
contextual you know some of us and this
is men and women right it's some of it
it's it's it's it's it's romantic you
know some is you you need something that
to people would call bizarre you know
going on Kink yeah some BDSM you know
going on so so that's why I wonder how
much of that was about sexual
stimulation in that situation versus you
not being sexually attracted to the
person so I wish we could almost go back
and and I could be your sexual surrogate
unfortunately yeah she's got a baby now
it made me pivot but I think you're
actually spot on because what I came to
learn a couple of years later was that I
had this one sort of one-dimensional
view of what sex was and then as I said
on this podcast once before when I
started viewing sex as potentially a
different set of languages yes I thought
[ __ ] I'm speaking English maybe she's
speaking Spanish yes there you go you
know and I need to learn a new language
in order to have an effective uh um
sexual conversation everything changed
absolutely and it changed for one of my
best friends too because he was having a
similar issue with his sex life and I
said what if you just saw it as like
your girlfriend speaks a different sex
language you're speaking one and you're
like ah I'm unsatisfied because she's
speaking Spanish and she's going uh I'm
unsatisfied she wants touch she wants
the the 30-minute non-penetrative build
up yes you want to tie her up you want
to gag it gag her and whip it and all
that kind of kinky BDSM stuff right
you need to talk you need to talk in the
language another language and then also
too because you drop penetration in
there yeah this is something that most
men I mean yeah men we need to know this
is that the vast majority 70 to 80 of
women need clitoral stimulation not just
penetrative and I and and see I mean
this is see this is this is where
um the feedback once again
we have no feedback loop you know porn
that is our teacher yeah yeah you know
that's our teacher and what we have to
understand is is no there are I love
what you're saying there are different
languages sexual languages you have to
understand how your partner the language
that they speak sex in and you have to
deliver it and that's also why
communication is the Bedrock of all
relationships it really is
yeah
that's so true thinking about how I
could have fixed that situation
um because I you're right I totally
dismissed it and I didn't do any work
that was the very much characteristic of
my younger self which was if something
and this is relationship sex whatever it
was if something isn't perfect now
go go just run don't do any work to like
to have the conversation to to fix it to
have empathy for someone else might have
a different opinion or a different bias
or a different attachment style if it's
not perfect I would Dash yeah I'll go in
search of perfect which doesn't exist
yeah and but this is I mean you know
this is all of us this this is
immaturity yeah and that's that's the
beauty of learning you know as you grow
older
on that point of seeking Perfection
um and I asked it a second ago but we
got we got one off on the sex thing
um
um do we know what we're looking for
are people good at saying this is what I
want
Hells no we are terrible we're all
biased when it when it comes to to love
you know I've done a lot of research
around biases and when it comes to love
it's like we're wearing the foggiest
glasses known to you know known known to
human beings we're terrible when it
comes to making any type of rational
decision around our love life you know
normally we are looking for ourselves
like we literally are are looking for
ourselves it's it's funny to me um when
you see someone when you ask someone
well what is your type which I hate that
phrase but you say well what is your
type and typically people will describe
someone who's very much like themselves
very much like themselves in so many of
these categories and so we we are
horrendously bad at not only identifying
what works well with us but then making
selection and on top of that most women
don't make the selection it's typically
the man who makes the selection and this
is where I say that what I like what I'm
seeing now is more women are are being
are consciously choosing who and what
they want in their relationship opposed
to being the ones who are always
selected
why does that happen why am why are
women not choosing is it because yeah
because yeah I mean it's it's it's it's
because of you know the craziness of of
of the world and how we've evolved you
know if you think about it was the pill
that was one of the first Liberation
points for women when it came to when it
came to dating
I mean and you think about it's that's
not that long ago we're talking about
the 60s we're talking about the 70s
really when the when the when the pill
became in Vogue you know if you will at
least in the United States and what that
allowed was for women to finally have a
little bit of choice when it came to
dating before that it was it was
virtually men making the selection
making the choice you're mine or you're
pregnant so you're definitely mine and
that was it and then you saw a little
bit of Liberation come from the pill
which was incredible but then also
what's great now is the dating apps I
know the dating apps get a lot of a lot
of stick
for whatever reasons and yes we should
always hold dating apps accountable but
what's beautiful is that you do have
dating apps where you have given women a
lot more choice and control in the
dating experience which is important and
even when you look at the studies and
you look at the dating app ecosystems
that are that are led by women
they're safer they're less crude you
know the list goes on and on
interesting so are you saying that we
contrast is is tends to be better for
compatibility than finding someone who's
a replication of yourself uh all right
that's a good one so
a bit of a bit of contrast right a bit
of it it's almost like going back to the
weak tie Theory you know you want
someone I think
well let me say this the the best
matches I've seen are based on that
blueprint that I outlined from
attachment style all the way down to
physical attraction
but then context also plays a large role
you know if I were to place you on a
desolate island with someone I guarantee
that person's gonna be the love of your
life after you know I don't have babies
you can have lots of babies they're
gonna be you know you're so you're gonna
think they're your soul mate right so
context plays a large large role which
is why
it's interesting to see how politics
plays a role in dating you know just 20
years ago politics was insignificant in
dating it was not a topic that was
brought up
definitely not brought up on a first
date you know if your partner was on it
was has an opposing political view it's
completely fine
today
it's one of the top metrics behind
whether or not you want to match someone
this is politics there have been some
really interesting studies that showed
that I mean even how sexually obsessed
men are right we still would turn that
well it depends on on who you're talking
to but there's a significant percentage
of men but a vast majority of women who
would not have sex with someone that
they find physically attractive but yet
have opposing political beliefs
I mean that that but that's the context
that's the day and age that we live in
so so context I think plays it plays a
role as well do we have to work hard to
find someone because I think there's
there's kind of a prevailing narrative
that Serendipity will solve it for us
the world has changed tremendously we
don't have we don't go to church like we
used to we don't have these pubs or that
sort of institutions of community in our
lives so we're like predominantly more
lonely than ever living in full White
Walls in big old cities alone how
do we have to work hard to find that
person do we have to put in work yeah
that's that's a great question I think
we should
I think we should put in the work I
think that we should put effort towards
anything that we have interest in so if
a romantic interest is something that
you want to have you you should put the
work in but I don't necessarily think
it's about putting the work into someone
else it's about putting the work into
you right and just elevating you
optimizing you making you the best you
can be upping your communication right
understanding how to build emotional
ties right understanding how to make
great decisions understanding how to be
a great listener critical thinker right
all of these things are going to help
you in all aspects of life and
definitely in your romantic life so
that's the whole that's where the hard
work needs to go in but we're in an
interesting place because
every generation believes their
generation had it the hardest when it
comes to finding a spouse this is
throughout time talk to my grandfather
my grandfather oh man you won't believe
how hard I had it you know and my
grandfather had three options
three options three options right small
village in Jamaica three options three
people
but what I find interesting is there's a
book Paradox of Choice by Barry Schwartz
and he's the less is more right and
what's interesting is that we have more
options today than say my grandfather
had in his day but it's we have less
satisfaction in the choices we make
because we believe we have endless
Choice that's the real problem that we
have so you think about you go on to a
dating app right how many people can you
swipe through in a dating app
endless it's endless you you could
literally 10 000 if you want to and the
thought is that you have an option all
ten thousand are option so because you
have ten thousand options and you pick
one
there's less value that you have in the
one but if I flipped it around maybe
this is the idea see I should pitch you
on this idea right now all right dating
app yeah this is my pitch dating app
but you only get three options
a week
interesting what do you think what do
you think because here so here's my
thought oh so so here's my thought right
the thought is that you place more value
in the option you choose
right
and that's ultimately I think what the
challenge is in this day and age it's
about we think you know we're placing
less value because we believe that we
have we have endless option so true the
the issue with the idea is in a world
where there are other apps like if that
app existed and it was the only app then
it would be the conversion rate from
first date to marriage I think would be
considerably harder and higher however
in a world where I can also use Tinder
or hinge when they're going to give me
ten thousand options I think people will
always choose option so I think would
have a problem getting users because
they'd go well I'd rather have a
thousand guys to choose from or a
thousand women to choose from
um but but your point is so spot-on that
a lack of options
um means we can we'll invest more and
work harder on the ones we do have to
make to make them work whereas if I if I
meet you on a date and I don't feel like
it's Perfection okay [ __ ] this I'll I've
got 37 men in my Tinder DMS that wanted
to meet me as well so I could try one of
them yep
and there's always we're always
contending with the false
highlight real x uh reality of those 36
other men right because they looked
perfect they did they chose the best
three selfies yep and they had he had a
Rolex on and he you know so and then you
meet him and you go [ __ ] yeah
but I'm gonna go to the 36 others yeah
yeah exactly and that's a horrific
spiral
um
another question I had was about honesty
from the jump
you go on a first date you meet someone
how honest should I be yeah should I
tell them about my childhood trauma on
the first day it's like is that being
authentic or is that offloading yeah
yeah well you know Chris Rock said it
best you know when you meet someone
especially on a date you're not meeting
them you're meeting their representative
you know so from that standpoint we have
to understand that there is a boundary
negotiation that happens especially on
these first dates and it is that that
tennis game again right so what you're
trying to do ultimately is you're trying
done and let me even back up can I say
this about for one is that I think
we I think most of us do the first date
completely wrong entirely wrong we set
ourselves up from the jump to fail
miserably and be disappointed and the
reason why is because it the the first
date is too intricate it's too big you
know it's dinner but to prepare for
dinner I'm gonna buy a new whatever you
know I'm gonna get my hair done you know
I'm gonna get this I'm gonna buy this
new thing I'm gonna get the car wash I'm
gonna do all this stuff we've spent
we've invested so much
that we've set ourselves up for failure
also a first date quite honestly over
dinner is an interview it always turns
into an interview and then the culture
I've noticed in the UK is fascinating is
that this is not everyone but typically
I notice is we're going to get
completely pissed before the date like
so we can talk to each other so we're
just gonna drink drink drink drink drink
okay now let's talk to each other and so
it becomes we set ourselves up for
having a very costly date in time effort
res all resources instead it sounds so
simple I like meetups let's not let's
even take the pressure off of of the
date situation let's call it a meet-up
30 minutes let's have coffee right the
reason why I love that or a walk
sounds stupid right no a walk for 30
minutes let's just go walk at lunch
let's go go take a walk the reason why I
love that is because
the expectation is so much lower in that
situation so much lower the cost so much
lower right so the investment right so
much lower so therefore that return on
investment potentially so much higher
but then also psychologically what I
love is is happening is is if it's
coffee caffeine if it's a walk it's in
endorphins going right those help us to
bond right opposed to alcohol that's a
depressant right it's it's it's doing
it's doing the opposite so in terms of
elucidating ourselves for great
conversation
and preparing ourselves for Success a
walk or a coffee is great the other part
of that is I've had mil like not
Millions I've had let's say thousands of
clients who have said okay
tell in particular this is for ladies
telling men tell the guy that you want
to meet him for coffee in the day
a lot of guys I'm not doing that yeah
because they want to get laid
they're like I'm not doing that right so
right away it's a good filter it's a
great filter it's an easy filter for you
you know so that's part of that and then
if it works well and when I say if it
works well is you just need two things
on that Meetup
are you physically attracted to them
minimally and then did they listen to
you so if you have the ability to
communicate they listened critically you
listen critically and you're physically
attracted that is chemistry
because we have a hard time defining
what is chemistry you say what is
chemistry what's the buzz what does that
mean and everyone's like I don't know I
don't know it is I think one part
physical attraction Mutual physical
attraction another part critical
listening listening if you have that you
have enough to move forward and then see
each other in another environment you
know it's so true because I'm just
reflecting on how many of my friends
both men and women will come back from a
date that didn't work out and just
resentfully talk about how much they've
spent
and how and how much it cost like how
long it costs them yes and how much
money it costs them and the preparation
of the facial and the hair and the nails
and and they sit there resentfully and
so you you you're right bringing that
level of expectation to a to a first
encounter
you know mo goddess out here and said
we're happy when our expectations of how
life is supposed to be going go are met
and we're unhappy when our expectations
of how life is supposed to be going go
unmet I'm coming in with one ahead of an
expectation that you're going to be my
husband yes I've put in all the work all
the investment the time three hours and
then if you fall anywhere below that for
whatever reason I'm probably looking for
you know
oh God it's not you're almost setting
yourself up to fail by by doing such a
huge initial upfront investment yes and
you know what you you were making I
think a a brilliant brilliant point
there is that when you've made that
investment what you end up doing is
you're looking for reasons to weed them
out yeah because you're like oh man I
did all this yeah and his trainers yeah
what trainers is this guy where oh my
God you see the train those are last
year's trade I bought new shoes for this
year yeah yeah it's crazy crazy crazy
crazy what what are you struggling with
in your relationship ah man you know it
is
time
really time quality time it is it is it
is I would say time but quality time be
because I am you know it right now I'm
predominantly doing television work and
and I've been in TV now you know for uh
since Oprah you know so 12 13 years it's
so so it's it's been a while and one
thing I've noticed about the television
space is that there are moments when
you're hot
and their moments when you're not
and when you're hot it's that's the time
to leverage and so you have to you're
already working your ass off but you
better work it off even more and so I'm
in that zone right now I mean I'm
blessed I'm co-hosting two shows I'm
contributing to three shows one in the
states two here in the UK so it's one of
these where I'm constantly work every
day every day in work every day I'm
working so
that time
with my wife that time with my children
that's the time that I wish I can get
some back
how are you negotiating that how are you
serving the ball over the net in terms
of the tennis analogy to make sure
things aren't you know she still feels
like a priority and your family still
feel like a priority yeah that's a great
one I mean finding those moments and
making sure that we're in or should I
say making sure that we're intentional
about the moments that we do have right
so this morning for example before I
came over here we had breakfast together
went out had breakfast together sat
talked with the dog right those moments
are
immeasurable right those moments right
to have those moments together
um I dropped my boys off at school right
walk you walk them 10 minutes to school
10 minutes the other to the bus those
moments immeasurable you know when I was
you know getting helping them dress
tying their ties those moments and
making sure that I'm fully in those
moments not I'm in that moment but I'm
on my phone at the same time I'm in that
moment oh I've got to post this on
Instagram no phone goes away right phone
goes away and so making sure that the
moments that we have that I'm fully I'm
fully in them and then also I think
gratitude is something that
is is very important and I've been
practicing this for I don't know six
seven years but being appreciative of
those moments and then reflecting upon
those you know so every morning the
first thing I do in the morning is I I
consciously think about the moments
yesterday that I'm appreciative of and
what I find myself doing is I'm rarely
thinking about oh I'm so happy this
happened at work or I'm so happy about
the ratings of this it's always
I'm so happy that my son who's 11 held
by hand walking to the bus he's 11 but
he still held my hand you know I'm so
happy that my son came over and he asked
me to tie his tie he gave me a kiss on
the cheek and said thank you Dad like
those are the moments that really get to
me and that's when I I wake up thinking
about and I'm able to think about it
because I was in the moment fully
and what's talk to me about the near
term then what are you working on in the
near term I know you've got we don't
even talk about it today but you got
multiple revenue streams all over the
place you're an entrepreneur you've got
two two or three TV shows that you're
working on simultaneously which is
absurd yes all of these things going on
in your life what am I what give me a
picture of your full your professional
portfolio per se okay so so there are a
lot of things happening uh and they're
all in different categories so so on the
television side I am I'm co-hosting
Married at First Sight UK and I'm also
co-hosting celebs go dating we're in our
11th series of subsco dating in our
seventh uh of uh of Merit for a site so
so so those are those are big entities I
contribute to the Lorraine show oh yeah
and also to steps to pack lunch here and
then in the United States I'm a
contributor to Good Morning America
right so that by itself are those are a
couple full times right but that's
that's kind of like the TV side do you
have a podcast I do I I did like a years
ago I I did but I mean quite honestly
looking at this
and you know you are and and this is me
not trying to trying to gas you up is
that you are incredibly inspiring in
credibly inspiring and I and you know
what's interesting is I I I I look at
you and I think okay God this guy's
younger than me you know how is the he's
he's so much younger than me and he's
inspiring you right and what it is is
that you pursue excellence
to a degree I don't know if I've ever
witnessed I'm talking about I've worked
with some of the top billionaires in the
world I've interviewed I was a business
columnist for USA Today and I
interviewed some of the most successful
entrepreneurs
like period and your level of pursuit of
Excellence surpasses
them where's my billion yeah but see
it's not about the boots but it's not
about that yeah you know you're and and
and and so all I say is that so you are
incredibly inspiring to me and to to
many people and to the question around
the podcast is part of that inspiration
is like
this is a great space you know to get
into so that's something that is in the
back of my mind but I'm not actively
pursuing it that's very kind it makes me
feel really uncomfortable that's why I
cracked up
it's a huge compliment and I I received
the compliment and I I believe what
you're saying it just you know makes you
feel uncomfortable because I you know I
don't know why it just makes me feel
uncomfortable when I when I
I really appreciate it and I believe
every word you said
um I believe you meant every word you
said
um and I know that we are I think the
reason why our team will be successful
in pretty much anything we do is because
of what you said so it's because I think
we care more about the small stuff yes
and that's where for me Excellence
begins we can all make the big decisions
to start a podcast as a big decision it
doesn't guarantee success it's all the
tiny things that people that are easy to
do but also easy not to do that end up
defining your trajectory and over the
last I think two years in particular
actually because of this podcast and
actually because it's so data Centric
and I look at lines and charts and how
one decision that like the team and I
make or what that Jack makes can just
tilt the direction of the line right and
I go and it's been this reinforcer to me
that in fact the the most important
things and and the biggest opportunity
is the smallest things everyone else
nobody else cares about yes they'll be
thinking about let's get a bigger guest
or like you know let's get you know the
big stuff but it's the smallest stuff
where we have our opportunity yes um so
you've identified something that I hold
very true and I consider to be my
professional religion
um and I appreciate the compliment it
means a lot no no definitely and and you
just I think destroyed a myth that
exists as well and that is that we
should be sweating the small stuff yeah
100 yeah you know the whole oh don't
swear no sweat the small stuff because
that's where greatest change comes the
same thing with your romantic
relationships people I don't support the
spot no that one miss hug you know that
one missed I love you let's correct it
now correct it now yeah
so so powerful I we have a closing
tradition on this podcast
where the last guest leaves a question
for the next guest they don't know who
they're leaving it for okay okay so it's
kind of a through line all the guests
having a conversation with each other
um and I don't get to read the question
until I open the book
um
when was the last time
you cried of Happiness oh my gosh cryd
of happiness
oh my gosh I know I mean I've cried
tears of sadness recently
um
you've corrected some sound just
recently yeah man I mean my
sister-in-law passed away two weeks ago
uh Mike I've had I mean I've had a
string of passings in my family that is
just
devastating devastating first funeral
I had to plan you know my wife and I
planned uh just I mean just yeah one of
those so so I you know I think I think
of
tears of sadness what did that teach you
about life
is someone young and short goes like
this
I've uh I've been at two Death Beds
one of someone who I would call
incredibly young and another one who
someone who's lived a full life
they both said the same thing and it
haunts me they both said
this thing goes by quick
life goes by quick
that's all we get and it gives me chills
because I think about them looking at me
and that's part of why I think I have
lived the life or live life the way I
live it and why I focus so much in the
moment and why I try to express how I
feel about people in the moment because
we may never get the moment again you
know
um so so yeah it's it's taught me I mean
to write a eulogy
to have to write a eulogy you know for
someone so young
it it did I will say some practical
things though it taught me well it it
taught me we all need Wills
we all need a will
I think that we all should be
consciously aware of
how we want to be laid to rest
it's a major debate that happens in the
family and you know
to have that consciously thought out so
that we so that people can your loved
ones can honor you in the way that you
want to be honored I think is incredibly
important
um so to have a will and to have
pre-thought some of this it's it's not
morbid I think we have to understand
this is part of our humanities that we
will not be here you know forever so
those are thoughts that are practical
thoughts that I've taken and now I have
a will now I've written you know how
where I want to be buried how I want to
be buried these are incredibly important
um
I cried like I cried for
it could be 30 40 minutes straight at my
wedding
I just cried I cried the entire wedding
I just cried and cried and cried and
cried all the pictures of me crying
right so uh those are those are probably
that's the last tears of
tears of happiness but I'm I'm
incredibly happy
but more than that I'm appreciative
you know I'm appreciative of life and
it's actually the tears of sadness
that's allowed me to be appreciative
well Paul thank you
um my team met you a couple of weeks ago
and they
are obsessed with you and it's and it's
funny because it's not necessarily it's
because of who you were as a person to
all of them how you treated them how
wonderful you are how you know it's all
the small stuff it's kind of the stuff
you said at the start about that
Underdog and reaching out to the person
that might be stood up against the wall
it's all about stuff where everyone in
this building I wasn't here I think I
was out of the country if I remember
correctly but when you came to this
building they were just you converted
them into raving fans and I don't know
how long you were here or how much you
paid them
a lot okay that explains it they were
just all absolute super fans of yours
and your whole philosophy you said
something
you said something to someone I'm not
entirely sure who it was you know
because we'd asked we'd essentially ask
you to come and help us with something
with a project we're working on which
I'm very excited about
um and you said something almost about
like Karma where you were you do you do
things for people because you kind of
believe in planting that seed yes you
don't know when it will yes it will
flourish or when it will you know come
to fruition but you just do good with
the belief that like
Karma yes
and
such an important way to live and you
actually helped me to realize that
because the impact you had on all these
people here you turned all of them into
disciples and they're like fairly
influential people that that you know
they're well connected we've got a lot
of interesting people coming here you
know several days a week
amazing and then today having had a
chance to sit with you and ask you some
questions that really a lot of the
questions I ask for my own selfish
pursuit of trying to figure [ __ ] out
you've you've changed a lot in me and
you're going to change a lot in my
relationships I'm partly sat here
you know wine in this podcast up so I
can go fix some [ __ ]
and I think a lot of people that have
listened to this conversation will be
feeling the same way tremendous value
tremendously kind man
um even when the cameras are off you're
just a class Class Act
um and I have no doubt that you're going
to get everything you deserve that we
talked about that sort of like long tail
lagging and value yes you're gonna it's
gonna be your future is gonna be immense
yeah
I'm honored I'm appreciative I love you
I love your team right I really do uh
and um it's an honor to to be here so
thank you so much for having me I and
all of my team love you too I can speak
on behalf of all of them thank you Paul
thank you thank you
quick one we have a brand new sponsor on
this podcast which I'm very excited to
tell you about they're a brand called
Blue Jeans by Verizon and they are a
video conferencing and collaboration
tool that has changed the game for our
team as someone who's on calls pretty
much eighty percent of the day building
my business is and speaking to my teams
all over the world it's the guaranteed
security that differentiates blue jeans
from all of the other options that are
out there in terms of video conferencing
their Enterprise grade security means
you can protect your organization from
malicious attacks and establish real
trust with everyone that joins your
meeting and that is something there are
so many things that make sense and make
blue jeans
um a better option than the sort of
competitors out there and I'll be
talking about all of those aspects those
features and the reasons why I use blue
jeans in the coming episodes if you want
to check it out you can head to
www.blueens.com to learn more
[Music]
foreign
[Music]